marijuana has high levels of  tetrahydrocannabinol or THC CBD which  comes from the hemp plant has no more  than 0.3% of THC so it doesn't have as  much as the psychoactive components that  you would see in marijuana so as far as  being concerned about that it's it's  much less of a psychoactive medication  whether it works that's a good question  the FDA is working on that as we speak  everybody seems to be coming out with a  new CBD product now the question is are  there other products in there  contaminants pesticides that could be  affecting your sleep could could affect  the effectiveness of it I would look for  what's called a certificate of accuracy  and I would continue to follow the FDA  to see what they approve